we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be
drunk
[Music]
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk episode who knows what we've been
drinking we're all over the road you're
back from a flight
i'm leaving tomorrow on a jet plane
love that song great tune you ever see
the movie the guard
no it's uh it's john michael mcdonough
made it it's uh
it's brendan gleason and don cheadle oh
wow it's a
one of the i think it's one of the best
comedies the last 20 years it's amazing
how have i never heard of this martin
mcdonough's brother
who wrote like in bruges oh yeah and
they're they're related one of their
brothers but uh that's a great movie too
that's a great movie it's that tone
kind of dark comedy that's good brendan
gleason dude
yeah witty dialogue that guy's a hell of
an actor but they play leaving in the
jet plane for the credits and it's like
a great
use of it yeah even the bjork one is
good
i haven't heard that one oh man that's
how you know it's a good song when the
when the
bjork version is still killer is bjork
not good
well it's a bit much yeah we get it
you're weird
i don't i just don't know the work at
all she shows up to oh boy that's a good
pour there huh well i mean who are we
kidding here
yeah good point it's two in the morning
it's uh i don't even know what day it is
it's my pick so we're doing another
weird natty one i like it
i'm learning a lot here uh trying to
[ __ ] me with these uh these cool wines
you know like you're trying to show off
i just like mixing it up oh mix it up i
come in here with a bottle of hooch and
whiskey and all this
oh that is amazing i'm not a huge wine
guy and i like it this natural wine got
me in because it's so funky you never
know what it's going to taste like and
this guy who choked
he just passed away he was a winemaking
legend from australia wow
49 years old oh my god that's so sad
yeah making legend how cool is that yeah
so i was at the store a while back and
the guy was like you got to get this
because it's our last bottle
and this stuff is going to be really
hard to find because he just passed away
wow good eggs man if i was if i was a
lady i'd be
[ __ ] indian now you're more important
thank you
thank you i appreciate it you'll
appreciate it you're a drinker
this is really good and it's thin it's a
thinner wine which i like
you know sometimes why did they get the
wooden tongue the purple teeth if you
were a lady i'd say you're
thin somebody get me a towel to sit on
yeah you're really charming the pants oh
this is good stuff good
really good you have a good night i ran
into you at the stand you were
filming filming some stuff i don't wanna
i don't wanna give it away
but uh we're working on a cool video
idea
based on another video idea it's it's
quirky it's weird it's different it's
outside the box it's an ochata
of comedy it's gonna die
no it seemed like people were loving it
when i was there yeah it's going well
it's going well it's a whole new weird
thing i'm trying and uh that that was it
i'm not
i'm not changing my act i'm not becoming
one of these weirdo uh ukulele guys
you're gonna start beatboxing on stage
like damn it this guy's
he's changed yeah people always try to
add a new thing with a
with an easel or beatboxing it's like i
don't know just do the act
yeah it's i mean i the easel at least
dimitri martin was like
really creative with it like i get like
those one liner guys feel like they have
to add something
yeah definitely even steven wright had a
guitar sometimes
yeah and hedberg had the the chuck yeah
chuck in the back stan hope had a had a
guitar
he did on um
on one of them yeah one of the albums
had a guitar one
something to take the edge off but he
didn't have it no
no but he had i think was henry phillips
playing oh and it was that bobby barnett
story which is amazing
amazing henry phillips look him up too
he's hilarious so funny
punching the clowns his movie great a
lot of our a lot of our friends are in
there
[Music]
yeah always amazes me when a guy's like
i'm a comic but i've always wanted to
make a movie and he just makes a movie
that's so cool like i don't have that in
me you do you were getting filmed
tonight what are you talking about but
that's like hey me and this guy have an
idea we go shoot it like sitting down
writing the script and then getting the
actors together
i mean that is a whole to do you know
what you need is someone you need like a
guy who's really organized
yeah you write it yes you have great
ideas but you need someone who's just
like
mark sit down right right that's what
you need yeah and that's why money is
great like we have a little more money
than we used to
so this guy's like hey i'm gonna come
film you here and i was like oh
i gotta book travel can you book it and
i'll just give you money and he's like
sure then i'll just give him an extra
couple bucks cause he booked it and i
need to pay him the money for it
that's a good point yeah there is
something about uh having someone else i
mean i
wrote a show with uh you know with a guy
who's a veteran who like knew how to do
this [ __ ] and i was like yeah i wouldn't
i wouldn't have known how to do this oh
it's huge and then you start to
understand improv and sketch like
there's a whole team there
it must be i mean i don't wanna improv
troupe follow me around but
you know it's gotta be nice to have a
little uh backup i would love to write
it like a movie i think that'd be
awesome
really yeah why not man i tried in
college and i got like 40 pages in then
you start going
oh i don't know if this makes sense
what's the what's uh act two what's act
three what's the arc what's the
because you need a guy who's like a
primer whose primary thing is
writing scripts with you exactly and
then you just you'd have it
right that's why so many people write
it's like it'll be like screenplay and
it's like four names
yeah that's true i always wondered about
that well a lot of times i guess it's
like two people
who wrote it and then like another two
are like we co-wrote it but they just
like changed like four lines
yeah but they're more famous right and
then there's teleplay
yeah script i don't know what any of
that means screenwriting
written by there's always all these
weird little terms i never know
i think you'd write a great script i
appreciate it i like the dialogue
part but that's what your act is it's
like someone you have that rodney
dangerfield thing where someone like
sets you up to say the funny thing
yeah i can do the dialogue i bet but the
actual uh
character development and then the arc
of the story and it has to
be a conflict and a resolution that's
the part that kills me
yeah the the the story structure which
you are a story you're great at stories
i don't think i am i mean you got some i
mean you put it at the end of your act
for a reason i mean it's
a big well it's hard to find spelling
yeah that's it's not just like
it's like you're burying yourself it's
hard to be doing like a lot of jokes and
then tell a long story and then go right
back into jokes that's true that's true
in terms of the rhythm you're they're
just like wait what but you got that
white knight man that that's your white
whale
i mean you would text me at 4am this is
four years in the making like maybe this
is the ending maybe that's the ending
and i was like oh that's not bad and
then
two years later maybe this is the ending
and i just pictured you with a [ __ ]
uh
cigar sitting in an ashtray you got a
bottle of bourbon like
god this white knight story look that up
what special is that on uh it's the end
of i got this yes that's the closer
that's funny i remember colin quinn
being like
huh like i was running angles by him and
he's like nah that doesn't work
i remember like running by people like
what do i do i can't figure this out
yeah you i picture like a like a
beautiful mind you got a huge chalkboard
and you're in your bedroom and you're
just like ah i can't crack it
it was tough stories are but they take a
lot of work
they take a lot of work i would think of
this story there's a story about leonard
cohen like
i relate so much to this story in terms
of like how hard it is for me to write
something i like
yeah uh but he met bob dylan for lunch
wow or something like that and he was
like oh you wrote this song i love
uh you know and and bob dylan's like oh
you wrote a song like i love hallelujah
how long did it take you away it's like
five years he goes you wrote this song
like
how long did that take you when he goes
oh it was like 30 minutes ah
isn't that crazy but i relate to the
five years right you just agonized
of course of course yeah that bit took
me forever actually i didn't know i i
just put it i just had to shelf and just
say i forget i'll come back to in like
two years you gotta step back every now
and then because you get lost in it it's
just like
it consumes you and you can't see it
clearly because you're in the middle of
it you got to get out of it and look at
it for what it is
yeah you got to do you you'd be a great
story person you just stick to jokes so
yeah i stick to jokes i worry i mean if
i have a joke with a setup that's
a little bit longer than my normal subs
i feel like i'm losing them then you see
one girl go pee and you're like oh
i'm i'm [ __ ] she's gone what would
your therapist say though he'd be like
they're
they're connecting you i know i know
although that might not be true with
some of these strip malls sometimes
they're just they're just like no i just
want to check a text it's a long
there's a long bed i was in miami a few
weeks ago and if you have
two syllables extra they are doing a
rail
off the table you know they gotta
they're ordering a drink they're they're
blowing somebody it was it was tough
they're getting a jet ski online you
know so like that was
that miami is like you gotta you have a
tight act i had a i had a gig in spokane
the friday early show they were just
animals
just truly animals they drink out there
yeah they really do like the rest of the
weekend they were good but this one show
they just
i was just they're just i'll do a thing
sometimes i'm like give me a topic just
so i'll riff on it the way like that
setlist show works
yeah all right if i can riff on this you
do that to the crap sometimes yeah
at the end of shows because i try to
come up with bits sure sure so and if
i'm bored with
the jokes you know i just do that and
usually i'll get good
and i'll try to write jokes about stuff
so i can kind of like be like let me try
to slide this joke in let me slide this
joking
yeah but they're just yelling all at the
same time
you know this isn't working right right
but they're just so drunk they're like
do my thing do me interact with me
it's so funny how that works like we
have all these tight jokes that
are tried and true and tested just
tonight i was bombing i did an outdoor
show which is
i think i'm done with i'm giving up
outdoor shows cold turkey it's horrible
i walk a little stand and there's like
an ambulance going by while someone's on
stage i'm like
i think we're good yeah i think we got
this yeah
it was for the
uh yeah it's a nightmare and i did it
tonight it's the last one i'm putting my
foot down
but uh and i'm stubbing and [ __ ] on the
sidewalk i'm done with it but
uh a lady was filming me this asian girl
was filming me and i was like
ah ma'am could you just not do that i
know a guy who just got
uh you know his career ruined by saying
an asian joke i'm trying to hold back
could you put the camera away yada yada
and uh she was cool about she's like oh
sorry sorry but it's just
that was killing harder than my act
because it's it's in the moment it's
right there you could see her you got
that and they knew the story all of them
some of them did yeah these are comedy
fans probably half of them knew but i
was still
zinging and zanging a little but uh that
they were like oh
[ __ ] this is crazy because it's it's a
moment instead of just
the other day i was at the store and you
know you kind of get into that
joke rhythm right and then it's like a
lullaby almost
right but yeah she was she was nice yeah
that's good
that's uh where were you this weekend
baltimore right yes that's right yeah
baltimore it was great we sold it all
it's so funny i mean i don't want to get
too in the weeds of comedy but
i get a text on on tuesday hey man you
got to start promoting tickets are rough
and then i did that la run bobby lee and
chris d and all these other marin sold
out out of the show sold out
so incredible podcasts they work they
were also my mom heard you on marin
you got you got the the the bump
samurail's mom
i'll take it she knows comedy she she
she loves comedy and she was like that
was a pelvis she listens to maren
constantly it's so funny that my mom
listens to marin but she'll be like
she'll say like god he's such a
narcissist and he's so
full of himself and he's so you know
damaged and he's like but you like the
show she's like he's a great interviewer
he is great
he loves the show i was in the middle
you've done it yeah i was in the middle
of it going wow he's good like in the
middle of talking to him thinking this
guy's good he's pulling it out of here
he brought it extra because of you
though i think well you were bringing it
i think i was bringing it it makes him
bring it and you're like a foot away
from it's that tiny wooden table you're
in his
basement did you zoom it or you know i
was there okay because joel is it was a
big deal when i was there it was like
pete covid
oh wow and they were like will you go
and i was like
yeah ah it's barren yeah it was when i
was still
like the peak paranoia of it but that's
the thing about these
you know people [ __ ] on marin he's a
narcissist he's a [ __ ] he's he's prickly
but that's why it's a good show in a
weird way he is he is a legend and he
and i
and i do respect him definitely
definitely i mean i listened to him
before i did comedy and and enjoyed it
he did he's done like 40 conan's or
something he also recorded two albums at
the club
i performed at over the weekend uh
laughs in seattle is that
right so laughs is formerly it was first
called giggles
then it became a strip club they just
took the g off and called it jiggles
giggles to jiggles back to giggles yeah
and now it's laughs
and uh it was it was a good weekend yeah
that's a real mom and pop
kind of neighborhood club too it's like
right in the residential area i like
that room
have you ever done seattle the city i
did the tacoma underground no wait the
underground seattle underground
really i didn't do a weekend there but i
did a couple spots there
and it was good yeah it's like a classic
room yeah but i mean it was like heroin
all around yeah i heard that guy is uh
likes to dance with the uh oh you know
what the white the white horse
yeah the old yam yam but uh but seattle
doesn't really have clubs
i know it's a major city and they got
amazon there now so it's like you think
they'd be booming with clubs i mean
that's the
you just feel the wealth gap in that
city like there's literally like
40 homeless people and then like three
dudes fly by in a hovercraft and you're
like what the hell
i know i know but the beauty of it is
it's all white
so like you're like look at that white
piece of [ __ ] look at that rich guy and
they're all the same so you don't feel
bad
there's color involved you're like ah we
gotta help these people you know
that's true it is weird but it's like
you know what it feels like it feels
like
you like one corner is dawn of the dead
the next corner is like star trek or
something
yeah it's so true it's really and it's
like weed is legal there
oh yeah there's weed everywhere that you
smell it everywhere
yeah yeah it's so so many thrift stores
yeah
mike lawrence said this great joke he's
like i love seattle because you have so
many strains of weed and lesbian
and you're like that is such a perfect
damn seattle line
you know i opened with one that hit
where i said man i saw a homeless guy
smoking weed and i was like do you need
to be hungrier
but yeah we'll work for munchies
what uh yeah seattle was great though
it's one of the
one i've never done a weekend there no
it's a great town
good smart audiences too like they get
it they're they're comedy
people um i think sometimes those kind
of hipstery towns
like portland or seattle will over
compensate and
and like the dark stuff because they
know they have that crunchy
reputation dead on i think i think
you're totally right
and yeah i mean i remember i used to
have a bit about like a gator
the gator bit about the baby getting
eaten and uh
i worked it out in portland and it
bombed every show there was a seven
minute chunk where i bombed every show
and i wouldn't i wouldn't stop doing i
was like i thought by the end of the
week i was like i think i have to drop
it
whoa and then i and then i went to tampa
and where did they restore my confidence
that's funny because that has like over
a million views on youtube
a lot of them are hate oh really yeah
it's like that's the bit i've gotten the
most like threats over
i mean that's howard stern you know like
he's like yes sixty percent of my views
are if people hate me but hey and it's
views
yeah it's tough because i do feel like
i'm mocking the woman who is outraged
more than the baby
i feel like i made one i made one joke
about the baby and that outraged someone
right and the joke was really pretty
tame but then yeah that's a good point
but then
the woman got outraged so i mocked her
for like seven minutes
yeah and and people were like he's
making fun of a dead baby i'm like i
don't really feel like i am but
no they don't listen they just know the
the the the subject matter hey
like the crocodile at a kid and you're
doing a joke about that you're like no
you got to listen
yeah well she knew she tried to kind of
end me she tried to like get me fired
for
uh it was a new joke obviously it was
like a brand new news story i wrote it
like that day
yeah and then she was like he should not
be allowed to work there so i was
mocking her i mean
yeah that's it that's all it is folks
you gotta listen if you try to get me
fired i should at the very least get to
mock you in a comedy special
yes here here for doing comedy in a
comedy club
what do you want lady the marin
interview was so good that you told
these stories man like i mean the story
about getting
near mugged in the east village i know
true story and you're right i gotta do
it on stage at some point gotta do it on
stage
because it's so fascinating and that's
dude saved your ass
yeah it's got everything it's got layers
because like i judged them
i didn't judge this guy and i was
completely wrong can't judge a book
for those you know i'll give you a quick
version i came home i used to live in
crown heights
rough area and i saw five guys on the
corner shooting dice drinking 40s
you know out of a movie like central
casting you know the
cardboard on the ground you know jumping
up and down going nuts
rap music playing you know i sound like
i saw like an old man
they had the hippity hop playing and
these uh
smoking jazz cigarettes but um
so i was like all right i'm gonna just
cross the street and then an older guy
is coming towards me and i think he was
on pcp
or something he just picks me up he
tried to get my ipod he slammed me
against the business
these guys come over beat the [ __ ] out
of him i'm talking like kick him in the
face and
crazy [ __ ] and then i ran home and uh i
got away with it the cops said those are
drug dealers they can't have a white kid
getting
[ __ ] up in the neighborhood so they
had to step in wow yeah
and that was uh that has layers that
story yeah that was 2007 in new york
city back when it
you know had some edge it's funny that
you have a uh like this [ __ ] up
thought
you know you kind of profile yeah and
then you get saved by them i mean
there's there's
absolutely layers there like to have a
bad thought and then
to be saved is completely the opposite
yeah
i thought they were going to hurt me
they saved me this guy
but then they're still dealers yeah so
it's like that too
there's like those yeah so are they
heroes are they not heroes yeah it's
fascinating
it's like life baby it's complex kind of
like this red right here
full bodied very complex heavy goes down
easy
you never got mug you're from here you
never got mugged my brother did
oh really i never did no was it bad no
they just like
stole his watch it was like nothing it
was like a shitty watch gun
or anything knife ooh old school
yeah no i never got i got [ __ ] with i
never got mugged
i just i'd run away yeah well that's the
move
yeah [ __ ] with like like guys like
guys like cornering me and talking [ __ ]
oh yeah
i gotta just get away wow poor little
sam with a backpack on
um i'm thinking when it happened no it
was just like a sweater i was like
it was like a fleece or something that
was it yeah and they were like he's a
little white kid [ __ ] this kid
right and they [ __ ] with me and uh
nothing happened though my brother got
mugged and he wasn't even that worried
about it you know he's like he's like
that happens my brother my brother
my brother's pretty chill like yeah i
mean he works for the da's office he's
like oh wow
he's like a legit like chill kind of
he hates like he's uh he's so
left he's so far left in his views and
everything and he's so um
like he's he's a great guy but he's also
like very
uh he's always been against corruption
you know interesting like he used to
work for the ccrb the civilian complaint
review board was like
and [ __ ] and yeah now he's a da's office
like he's all about
stopping corrupt people this feels like
a like a tnt show
yeah man that's crazy morelli and isles
[Laughter]
yeah my brother's the exact same way
that's so funny we were so my mom was
freaked out because she was like
i didn't realize like mark and you are
like have similarities
oh yeah oh yeah but we really like i
think we have the same issue we've
talked about it we're like i think
a lot of comics like don't feel seen
like it's yes
it's not like we didn't get the
attention it's that we didn't feel seen
like you are such an example of that to
me because
even in the marathon you're talking
about how you know you're at this like
you know
you're at this public high school then
you're at the catholic heights yes yes
and like either way like that's not
neither of those are really you right
right exactly you didn't really fit in
it either
yeah plus workaholic parents military
ex-military parents not a lot of hugging
not a lot of loving
and then my dad is so [ __ ] up like
your dad was gone
but my dad i was raised by my dad i have
a dad
you had like a non-biological dad yeah
yeah he adopted me it's
like when i was seven he's a lawyer so
he wanted i want to legally adopt you
why i want to take you to a courtroom i
want it to be legal and yeah
great guy i love him and the brother too
i i assume no that's his biological son
oh
yeah he had two kids my siblings are
step siblings
so sad i'm learning all this on a pod i
know well the problem with you is we've
talked for like eight hours at a time
so i've definitely told you this [ __ ]
before but we're usually drinking yeah
well now it's good it's on tape i can
review the tape this is gonna be uh
episode 64. wait so you have a half
brother
i think i did know that i think you
definitely knew that i've told you this
[ __ ] a million times but we've
we've spent so many time so much time
talking that
a lot of [ __ ] just gets pushed out oh
yeah oh yeah and we're writing jokes
we're on the road as
we're meeting weird people yeah there's
a lot to a lot to hold on to but
was there ever friction like you're not
my real brother kind of [ __ ]
yeah those friends oh really not really
as much with us as it was
i think my mom there was a little more
friction because they already had a mom
who wasn't so it's understandable like
it's weird for
for me like my mom in the house
represents stability and like yeah
that's the only person i'd ever like
known sure and then for them it's like
it's a new
figure who's like a threatening figure i
think so authority it took a while they
were not warmed or for a long time so
that was i think tough i think i think
blended families knowing it's so it's so
common now but like the nuclear family
is kind of a thing of the past
it's sad but true yeah like mike gallis
pushing marriage and i'm like
i don't know mullany uh bezos uh gates i
mean
the writing's on the wall sister and
they're like successful people
but in six years you're dating olivia
munn i'm like you're like i told you
you did this to me well at least it's a
happy ending but uh
yeah boy john's got some big shoes to
fill aaron rodgers chris pine
the other guy yeah chris pine is one hot
man
that is like i'm i'm straight but i see
that dude and i'm like
[ __ ] i mean hell or high water he's
almost too hot that it's
it takes you out of it you're so right i
had the same thought like
he plays this like poor bank robber yeah
and his hair is incredible
i know beautiful hair the the the sweat
on the forehead
he's got the you know the shine from the
sun his tan
he is a gorgeous man yeah he is a
gorgeous gorgeous he's also a great
actor
great actor he uh dude hella high waters
one of the best movies the last 20 years
dude
so good i mean it was a little
archetype-y you know
the crazy brother the the son the
brother with the heart of gold
it was a little bit of that but it still
works it worked and bridges is
incredible and the dialogue is great and
the bank robbery scenes were
actually legit scary yeah yeah and they
felt and then jeff bridges is the fun
chief like police chief over the top
incredible great movie jeff bridges so
much
uh that was up for best picture i
believe i think so and ben foster is the
crazy brother right oh he is so good
that dude's just like totally like
the artsy actor i know he's so he's so
good in everything he's my favorite kind
of actor where you know you know you
don't really see him on the red carpet
he's not trying to do all the [ __ ]
hollywood
hubbub glitz and glamour he's like i
just want to be a good actor and do
great roles and do good work
he's so good though you're right that
that really i saw that with ryan
hamilton in the theater he's like my new
york movie buddy
and uh because we always end up living
again like nearby oh yeah
and uh we kept turning each other like
wow
i love seeing a movie with a friend we
just keep turning to each other like wow
yeah i used to just stay up late when i
was younger and watch
movies and you know you get a couple
duds every now and then but
well every now and then you come across
a movie like that at like you know one
in the morning you're like should i
watch it i'll be up till three
[ __ ] it let's do it you have a rice
krispie treat a [ __ ] beer in your
head and you're like whoa
damn and when it's a great movie it is
just you alone
in your quiet living room just deep
entrenched in this plot and story it's a
beautiful thing
the rice krispie tree wow you just
nailed it the best childhood
they got a little greedy with a
chocolate rice krispie treat it's like
we didn't need it
we're good yeah this is carrying this is
pulling its own weight you know how good
the rice crazy treat is they sell it at
starbucks which is like this kind of
cutesy artsy
uh coffee shop they have jazz playing
and everything and
blonde roast i still got a rice krispy
treat in there by the register
but they put it in the clear wrapper to
be like look at this
this is a fancy rice krispie treat i'm
fine with the blue rapper
yes yeah i'm fine with that too and and
a cheap one is good and an expensive one
is good
sometimes they're like this big and it's
a perfect square you know like at the
diners or whatever
man that is an underrated treat it's
weird that it's got a [ __ ] or a tire
in the fancier place
ah the clear wrapper yeah it's like a
see-through dress
yeah interesting interesting but it is a
damn good i mean yeah
as a kid that was probably my fa like
same i don't know if it got better than
a rice krispie treat you could make it
and you're with your mom and you're
stirring the [ __ ] and you eat some of
the raw
part you know before it goes in and you
gotta wait for it the anticipation
that was good stuff so good is it yeah
were there any other like
what's your movie go-to treats i'm a
reese's
guy i'm i'm all the way reese's pieces
reese's peanut butter cup the mini cup
but i also like a milk dud no that's a
good one i love the
the box i love how it's that bro like
cardboard box you can shake it how many
i got left you pour it in
oh i like a box how about the people
when they dump the treat in the popcorn
i don't know about that that's like the
autoerotic asphyxiation of childhood
movie going snacks
too much it's too much the popcorn's
good the candy's good you don't need to
combine them
you know yeah it's intense i don't it's
okay but yeah it's a little
i'm popcorn's good but i never have
movie popcorn's the best
buttery movie popcorn but you never feel
good after never never well you're just
like
shoveling it in you know it's so
unnecessary and it's so buttery
and it's so good and it's so good and
then you're like
wiping that seat down with your hands
you know we've all done it
the movie theater i mean i i know it's a
relic of the past there's some 22 year
old going huh well
i go to the arc light you know it's uh i
get a beer i get a steak and i'm like
you know they were climbing and [ __ ]
they got a candle that ain't what it is
it's all about throwing the [ __ ] on the
ground
rusty seats they crinkle and they they
got holes in them
that was what it was all i do kind of
like the the recliners
i kind of like it too but i we went
through the hardship
we earned it these guys got it right
away i used to have a joke about how i
saw
uh the movie 12 years a slave and one of
those like
that's great with it with a waiter would
come in it's like the time you really
feel bad
can i get you anything like you've done
plenty
one of my greatest memories i saw that
departed twice at alamo drafthouse i was
i was living in san antonio for a year
it was a wild
i never knew you lived in san antonio i
was shooting a i
was failing out of college basically my
dad's like i know a guy in the movie
business
you can be like a pa or a gopher on this
movie set it was like a b
movie called from mexico with love look
it up everyone give it a goog
and it never went anywhere in it that
you know one of the guys from scarface
is in it and
uh one of the guys from animal how that
guy mcgill mcgill
brian mcgill this guy was like the next
big thing this hot
mexican guy he never went anywhere but
uh
kuno becker i think that was his name
but yeah i was uh
i was just a gopher like get the coffee
get this and it was
it was a fantastic learning experience
and like
a wild time we go to strip clubs and
texas
and i had to live on a guy's couch for
like a year and i remember i was banging
the uh
like this pa girl with me and she was
like this hot mexican chick named sophia
and it was just a wild time but
uh i forgot my point how did we get to
this movies
oh oh yeah i would go why i was so
obsessed when i went to film school and
i was so obsessed with movies so my dad
was trying to get me like
on some kind of track like you're a
loser you're a bum
you know you're failing out of college
you're barely made out of high school
like go
be on these movie sets and i was like
i'll take it okay and it was an
adventure but i would go watch movies
when we had time off at the alamo draft
house
and it was like a beer and you could
have like uh you know enchiladas while
watching departed
it's the highlight of my life it is good
i mean i
i'm still like a classic like candy with
the movie guy but like
i like the movie theaters where they're
like like there's one
[ __ ] closed down upper west side
classic movie theater 60 something
street
broadway they would they would always
have like the foreign films the woody
allen films the indie films yeah
and they served cashews that's how you
know you're getting a good movie when
they've got cashews at the snack bar
was that the sunshine or the angelica no
no those are both downtown
in the 60s yeah sunshine angelica
angelica's great but the problem with
that is
it's right by the six train so every
once in a while you'll be in a pivotal
sea in a movie and you just hear a train
go by
i mean that really [ __ ] with the
suspense there that was rough that's
hilarious you hope you're watching uh
pelham one two three so it kind of can
match up maybe
but yeah that is tough damn you know
what i love in new york and this is this
is off topic i mean that movie stuff was
magical but
you know what i'm seeing a lot i live in
the west village and sixth avenue goes
right on my house it's like a big
thoroughfare or boulevard whatever you
want to call it and i'm seeing a lot of
like
kids i'm talking 15 16 on
bikes mini bikes scooters uh
mopeds and they're like doing wheelies
and there's like 20 of them 30 of them
yeah going down 6th avenue cutting in
between cars popping wheelies
and everybody's like oh you know these
old ladies are holding their purse and
it's like street kids you know and it's
like diverse and black and white and
hispanic and asian
and they're all like kind of dirty and
[ __ ] up i love that [ __ ]
yeah they're like the new warriors
they're like the warriors
they all go which i don't know what that
means but i watch them and
everybody hates them because they're
like ruining the village i guess but
like
i like it because they're not on the
internet they're not you know talking
about cancel culture or retweeting or
tick-tocking
these kids are out there shirtless doing
wheelies with a chain wallet and torn
pants
i love it they're living life and
they're actually
gonna get stories yes yes you don't get
any stories
what did you do in your 20s uh peaky
blinders
no these guys actually have they're
going to have stories yeah that's kind
of cool
they'll rob us at one point i'm sure
they'll they'll put a knife to our neck
but
i like that there's well i'm watching
peaky blinders on my phone
yeah take it here full circle yeah but
i mean i just like this these i'm sure
these kids are delinquents and hooligans
but like they got some life in them and
it feels like
the the youth is so uh watered down and
like
hey don't don't fat shame or whatever
which i get like i don't want you to be
mean but
these kids are like living you know and
then they're probably going back and
fingering a girl and drinking a 40
and i don't know it just seems it see
it's it's a relief
they're going to kidnap one of the new
hurst girls but uh other than that
no you're right there is there at least
have a uh
there's like an energy and an
originality yes yes
like there's an adventurism in there i
don't know if that's a word
i don't know either advent this they
have a they have adventurousness
is that a word maybe that's a good
scrabble word if it is a word that's got
a lot of
vowels but yeah no you're right they uh
they're living their own way and i
respect people that are like
doing anything kind of different against
the grain yeah
yeah i remember when i was a kid i think
this wine's hitting me
you're a skater get some over here
you'll see a little more yeah
anytime i hear when i was a kid
something good's coming up so let's get
in here well i was a skateboarder and
you know my parents were like these
intellectual
[ __ ] and they're always reading and
listening to classical music
and i heard my friend my dad's friend be
like oh escape
he's got a chain wallet you know he's
got long hair or whatever like
does that worry you and he was like no
i'm glad he's out there
getting in the sunshine like hanging out
with his friends
[ __ ] around like he's not doing
heroin he's like jumping off stairs and
trying [ __ ] they're filming stuff and i
i meant the world cup
in a lady [ __ ] you come here first yeah
right
we should do a thing called yahoos where
you did you guys do that was the
that's where you go in like a 7-11 or
something and you all grab a case of
beer and yell yahoo would run out i've
never done that you never did that
oh man but that's what that's what life
was like back then it was [ __ ] wild
and
yeah this korean guy pulled a gun on my
friend paul
and we we all ran out of there and he
was like oh he's like this fat kid with
pink cheeks
and the korean guy pulled a gun on him
and then so we all get back to the
meeting point we all have our cases
it's a great night we're like where's
paul and then we cut cut to
paul running down the street going ah
the green guy going
you know but he couldn't leave the store
so he had to run back but he's he's
chained like ned beatty and deliverance
[Laughter]
he gets uh he gets a plow from behind
from the korean
bodega owner but yeah god damn that's
incredible dude oh that was just that
was a tuesday i mean we were
it was new orleans it was lawless it was
pre-internet
pre-cell phone camera good times damn
dude that's great
yeah so that's why i see these kids and
i go these there's still some hope for
humanity
even though they are i'm sure they're
criminals yeah you know
just hope they're not like going too
hard with the drugs but uh yeah you hope
you know but uh [ __ ] that's the other
thing oh the attack of the screaming
beer thieves what is this harry
oh other people that's hilarious all
right
great it's still a thing all right good
yahoo
oh 2002. okay that was a different time
did you what did you guys do i mean you
were in the big city did you guys do
dine and ditch and [ __ ] like that but it
was nothing like yahoo sounds way fun
we would start we were bad kids in the
way we would start [ __ ] and like
it's dumb it's too dumb of course it's
all dumb we were we were idiots
i mean i remember we do like we're in a
pro wrestling so it's like we go and we
just grab an energy drink and pop it
and chug it but then throw it all over
ourselves and do like
the dx yeah we don't laugh you piece of
[ __ ]
yeah that's what you know whenever you
hear a girl she's like boys my age are
so immature you're like yeah
they are well i was in a boys school so
we were way worse i mean we were ten
times worse i mean it was like the [ __ ]
farts when farts are celebrated yes
that's the problem like you know you're
in a co-ed class you kind of like i'll
hold it in you're in an all-boys class
you're like
smell it i remember this is what's so
great about michelle wolf
besides the fact that she can drink like
a like an old she's got to be a future
guest on this we gotta get her on and
and she's gonna get that pennsylvania
accent drunk
i love when that comes out hershey's oh
my god
she definitely that episode would be
called we're definitely drunk
yes yes she'll come in drunk but
uh one time back in like early open mic
days and she was super new we
both were at a show in red hook like
you're just so desperate stage time
you're like i'll go to that i'll do that
i'll take a bus whatever it takes
we're both at a show on red hook you
know there's three people there it's in
the middle of nowhere it's some shitty
bar it's an ambush show and i'm sitting
in the back with her
and we're watching the show and i just
go
and i farted like huge huge just
you know and the guy on stage was like
what was that and she was like
and you know she's like such a cool
gal and she was like on her on their
[ __ ] hands and knees laughing at this
fart and i was like man this is great
that's [ __ ] going to see a lady you
know dying at a far but that's that's
wolf for you
i picture her laugh and it's making me
laugh i mean yeah that is
cool to have friends like that where you
can fart and like i remember
we were you know we were across the
street from this hotel in high school
and there would be people sometimes like
you know it's a hotel sometimes it'd be
changing with the windows open
oh yeah so we'd be in like math class
and i'd stand up and be like titties and
everyone would cheer
and they'd be like get out get outside
like but i just alerted everyone titty
so i'm like
i got like i got applause and i walked
out you know you're like that like the
guy
at the in the war who has the drums you
know you're like
i gotta start this thing that's a good
man as i'm dying i'm like
like say it one more time sammy like
titties
like damn it he was the comic relief
wow so crazy to see a hotel from your uh
from your school it was weird there's a
lot of good
stores from there i mean there's uh what
street was that
60 second between park and madison
browning yeah it was so weird dude you
know
um hey you got some good alumni from
that place howard dean
he's our most famous one okay that's a
good one
yeah he he had a good run remember that
was back when you got canceled for going
that's all that guy did and he got that
right oh yeah there was a chappelle
uh show sketch about it really all he
did was like do an
awkward celebration like when he ran for
president
yeah and they were like this guy's weird
[ __ ] him whoa
it wasn't buttoned up enough now now
it's like matt gates now it's like real
[ __ ]
yeah yeah i'm flying in 12 year olds um
oh we gotta we gotta speak it up is that
him
oh john d rockefeller wow oh okay so
he's better than us that's an old school
yeah that's old school hey old school
all right uh hey hey
speaking of speaking of rockefeller you
don't need to be when you're wearing
sheath underwear i love sheath i'm
literally wearing them right now i swear
to god look at that
i never take them off sheath is the best
in the biz they they look great they
feel good they're sexy they got the
the the segregated genitals with the uh
with the dicks
flap and the ball flap i
love it your dick and balls have been
they've been scraping up against each
other for
thousands of years generations finally
they got some space they got a
two-bedroom
i'll tell you man i was on the road all
for like six days i ended up adding a
show so i didn't have enough underwear
so i took go buy
to find underwear on the road i end up
finding a gap
i get i put it on in my hotel room it's
got no flat for your dog
this is the new craze designers are like
yeah it's like
25 underwear with new designs or no flap
we're supposed to piss over the roof
rather than go through the fence what
the [ __ ] wrong with you animals that's
crazy come on what are we savages
these are good i wear these underwear
it's great underwear great that's all
i've got i've gone full
sheath i used to be like a you know
other hanes or whatever i'm out it's all
sheath
that's all i wear they look good they
feel good they're supportive
the lady likes them they're kind of sexy
and and
they they hold everything up i'm a big
fan it's from a
us army soldier named robert patton uh
he
did you know two tours in iraq great in
twilight
yeah check him out he's veteran-owned
company he's a founder and a big comedy
fan he loves all of us
and he made a good product tell him how
to do it there sammy sheath underwear
dot com
uh promo code drunk and you get 20 off
with your first order
and sheath underwear 100 back money back
guarantee
that sheath underwear dot com promo code
drunk get sheath underwear and let them
support
your balls yeah you got that right
good stuff i like it now you got to
peeve or what i got a few
please i always have a few first off i'm
in this great hotel in spokane
amazing hotel so it taken work for me to
find complaints but i found one
20 little pillows one good pillow 20
little pillows
so with you the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] who
designed this a [ __ ] 14 year old girl
yeah that's what it is because you gotta
knock 19 of them off just to go to bed
but now
you wake up and you're like oh [ __ ]
you're stepping on pillows all day and
they take over the whole floor space
not only that you got to put three of
them together together to get a decent
pillow
that's so true and it's not it doesn't
work i hate the little pillows give me
one good pillow two i'm a human being i
mean it's sad when you're like maybe
i'll get a my pillow
that's not a good point in life you know
so yeah what's with the million people
and there's always that one long one
you know that goes on top i don't mind
the long one because sometimes i sit up
and i'll watch like
i watch basketball before better on the
road and i'll sit up on that and i'll
watch it so i'm okay with it a little
lower
lumbar lumbar support i'm okay with that
but i i need a good pillow and a lot of
these hotels
are skimping man yeah your head goes and
it just hits the bed
it go it's just like flat they spend so
much money on these rooms
get a [ __ ] decent pillow that's so
true good good point good point i mean
we're in hotels
every week and i just was in a hotel and
the pillow was amazing i can't remember
where i was and i remembered it i was
like wow the pillow is always shitty
and here it's great i think it was
actually tacoma they usually put those
guys put you in good hotels
yeah it's always like a swanky boutique
hotel definitely makes a big difference
man
hotel it's like i'm starting to value
quality of life i really used to stay in
some shitholes and i did not realize it
same same yeah you're just like ah this
is what it is you know this is how you
live
and then you're in a nice hotel and
you're like man this is making me not as
depressed to be on the road
i agree but i will push back and i don't
love
too nice like these super five star with
the
you know the the mint on the pillow and
the potpourri and all that because i'm
like
well it's 18.99 for wi-fi oh [ __ ]
because they got it they got in late on
the wi-fi they got some bad deal or
something right
so they started charging people it's
insane yeah and they figure well you're
already at the four seasons you can
afford 18.99 a day
so why the hell not move also on flights
you're flying from like new york to la
30 minutes of wi-fi 11.99 that's crazy
[ __ ] eat [ __ ] my move is i always say
it's not working very well i get a free
is that right i always pull that on
customer support
it never does work well that's true it
doesn't and i just spent 11 dollars
yeah and it takes forever to load and
you're like all right let me try
google.com oh no because you're waiting
for it to click over
and it it never works for me it's always
a nightmare drives me
a huge peeve of mine nick apollo is a
great joke i checked into a hotel there
was a [ __ ] in the toilet i said uh you
know most hotels leave a mint on my
pillow
classic road bit i think the mint is
over by the way
i don't i haven't seen a mint on a
pillow in 10 years it's been a while
yeah
wonder what that that's about what you
got to pee if
i gotta peeve and uh i hope we haven't
talked about this before but
i've been tweeting and whatnot you know
trying to work jokes out on twitter
and if you're if my joke is anywhere
near
kind of third railey in a dicey
territory i get the the lady going
hey look i'm a fan i think you're funny
but this joke
do better i'm done with do better
i hate do better you do better you're
reading my tweets
and you gotta comment on me you do
better you better should be for like
[ __ ] ex-con yes
it's so [ __ ] and vague and and like
dismissive you only said it to a
comedian you would never say that to at
a restaurant hey
do better right you would never say that
it's the lack of respect
and it and it really you know
condescending completely condescending
do better like
i don't know or this this is another one
i hate is when they go uh
you're better than this am i maybe i'm
not
let me not be better than this well i
remember i got in trouble for a joke
years ago in a comic that we both know
kind of
took a little shot at me and he goes yes
comedian you're yes fellow comedian was
already so smug
your joke was clever but don't you want
to be a little bit better than that
come on no like how about your act none
of it's clever right
right exactly it's that weird compliment
to it's like that misdirect compliment
to insult
like i'm a fan you're good but don't you
want to be a little better than that
i know what you think about the impact
of your comedy think about
who you're hurting would you ever say
that to tarantino you [ __ ]
exactly [ __ ] and the impact is a laugh
that's the impact i'm trying to get
not some i'm not trying to save the
world here and also
i think we do put a lot of thaw in our
jokes of course and also
maybe more than them when you work when
you walk a line
with jokes i do think you're gonna get
you're gonna [ __ ] you're gonna get
burned every once in a while that's how
it works i mean i just was a gotham and
[ __ ]
i joke so i'll put it this way they were
hitting all week and week in seattle
yeah and they were a little too [ __ ]
this crowd was a little too woke for it
i got them so
uh that's all right yeah yeah you know
it sucks because
it's like that bill birth thing like you
don't know what i'm i meant by that
you know but you're assuming i meant a
certain thing and you're putting that in
my
my act i didn't mean that i like it
though
dude i did it like 14 minutes into my
set where i was i was killing and
i kind of just went i went off a cliff
at the end i think people are kind of
conditioned especially on the coasts
that they're like oh that's a
radioactive territory i'm just hanging
back
even if it's great writing even if it's
a great point even if you're not wrong
that's that's dicey waters and i'm just
gonna to be safe i'm gonna hang back
and you you you they would laugh at that
if it was just you and them
in their living room but i think in
public
people now are kind of going i'm just
going to play it safe here
yeah it's almost like i don't want to be
on record yeah whereas in
you know seattle they're like ah there's
no record we're out we're having fun
seattle's awoke town though man i know
but i think it's but they were also
there for me
they're there for you and there's not as
i think there's a little more pressure
here and in la
and places like that and la is some
[ __ ] man oh yeah
new york can get annoying with that [ __ ]
but la's on another level
yeah it's so phony i was thinking about
what you said
and i feel like you need to think about
the impact of what you were saying
and uh think about maybe a more clever
way to say it
yeah you have a platform up there and
you should be using it
for better for you know for good instead
of your
pedophilia content like
all right do you know how many kids are
molested every year
uh do you no i just talk like this and
people
assume i'm smart right so maybe you
should stop pushing back
and just listen and then ironically the
only way to get them
is to go well i was molested and they go
oh my god you were you're like yeah how
about that
let me deal with my pain i don't know
maybe i might have blocked it out
but that's what i tell them just so they
leave me alone
it's weird it's the best response ever
you're a lesson yeah who knows
who knows i am a survivor somebody told
me i'm a survivor because i i lost my
virginity like a 55 year old when i was
16.
so in a way i am a pedophile survivor
i'm not a survivor you're a hero
i'm a hero yeah but somebody had to tell
me that they're like you know you're
like a survivor survivor of sexual
assault or whatever like oh i didn't
even think about it somebody made it at
the holocaust and you [ __ ] someone
who was older you get the same name i
don't know about that i never even
thought about it that never crossed my
mind i was like i [ __ ] an old lady was
awesome
she didn't charge me was it awesome it
was awesome yeah i
i loved every minute of it i i went up
there willingly into her hotel room i
met her dumb husband and
uh you're probably not a survivor then i
don't know that's what that but by
definition i'm like uh
i don't know there's got to be a
difference between i hate to be this
dude but there's i'm sorry there's a
difference between a 16 year old guy
and a 16 year old girl there it is there
is yeah this
i mean calling a girl fat from the stage
and calling a guy fat
different it's a different world and we
can deny it all day but it's just how it
is and you just go off the reactions
you can you can tell me i'm wrong women
are more judged for their body than men
are
of course of course and then you go
that's your girlfriend buddy man she's
out of your league and it gets a big
laugh
but if i was like that's your boyfriend
man he's way hotter than you you know
the girl's like geez i don't know it's
just different it's just how it is
i think like the fun fat guy is like
more celebrated than the fun fat girl
like definitely if you're the fun fat
guy you get a nickname like the tank or
something
right you're kind of like
so yeah you got there is a double
standard but there's got to be
but that's all there's some fairness to
it i think but yeah but that also proves
it's different whether it's for sure
good we are bad we are different yeah
for sure that's why it's annoying like
we're all the same it's like i don't
know
i mean you know it isn't because there's
a hashtag men
suck but if we're all the same shouldn't
be people suck it's funny you know it
was a lot of stuff with caitlyn jenner
because
she's running for she's running for
governor and
um following the footsteps of arnold
former figures of masculinity who now
have tits
and uh no but she uh
she had a thing where she said i don't
think trans people should get to compete
yeah yeah in sports which is interesting
coming from a trans person it changes
the game a little well you got to also
think it worked out perfectly for her
of course because she gets to be the
olympic hero as the man
yeah then you got to be the man for
another 40 years or so yeah and you know
what also is interesting about caitlyn
jenner and now we're going through a
whole
trans rabbit hole here but she's dating
a 25 year old trans person
oh really i didn't know that and you're
like that's pretty that feels kind of
man-ish
you're dating the young the young chick
i don't know i mean that feels like a
guy move
just saying pulling a sinatra here yeah
i mean you're pulling a sinatra a led
zeppelin a woody allen
what's that guy great balls of fire guy
uh you know
uh what's his name uh she's a
fascinating person
chuck berry she's a fascinating person
though oh
by the way every musician is [ __ ] a 14
year old of course
who's like who your grandparents listen
to they're like i like that so when you
when you're on this cancel thing it's
like all right i want to see your
playlist though
ah good point kelly yeah michael jackson
i'm not at all condoning but i'm saying
have some
consistency with the people that you
quote unquote hate of course of course
uh marvin gaye oh is that right yeah i
didn't know that one oh yeah
uh a lot of people so elvis presley
yeah yeah yeah how about um like we all
hate woody allen but
you know a lot of these guys but we all
secretly still like his movies
wow he's a talented man it's hard to
watch it now though but it's like
i still think some of his movies are
some of the best movies ever made of
course
of course that was a tough blow yeah
yeah
but then some kids say he did and some
of his kids say he didn't so then you're
like uh
who do we we want we want to believe he
didn't for so many reasons
yeah it's hard to believe i couldn't
watch the documentary i couldn't watch
it
because i think he did it really
i don't know i don't know enough but i
don't want to know enough i just i move
on i couldn't watch the michael jackson
one either
yeah that was tough i just think it's so
weird that we're like you made that
pedophile joke you
piece of [ __ ] oh michael jackson doc get
the popcorn
you know it's like it's theater but you
hated this stuff but it's theater
it's theater it's it's they're watching
it
like there is a sickness to like
watching this true crime
oh genre while you're just stuffing
goobers down your throat yeah and the
more gruesome the more entertaining
and you're like okay then it's like ted
bundy's cute i hear that every 10
minutes ted bundy's so hot he's not even
that good looking i never thought he was
either i mean it was pretty badass that
he's like
his own lawyer and all that [ __ ] then he
breaks out of prison when no one thought
he could
so like he's definitely a bad ass it's
also not a smart at all move i mean he's
kind of a [ __ ]
you know well i mean just he's just so
confident like
self-assured like i can i can ho i can
do this i can
you know defend myself at a court of law
and kind of
i guess it's not exactly my cousin
vinnie you know
great movie i love that movie marissa
tomei
that's one of the best comedies oh my
god rules
rules this cup this pod will always go
back to movies at some point
yeah because we both love movies that's
definitely the basis that was a big part
of our friendship early on probably
he's got i think he's from jersey bundy
no oh
i'm always obsessed with people are from
he's jersey yeah
he produced jersey boys is that right
yeah oh wow you know he hates
acting he likes he wanted to be a singer
growing up he was in a comedy troupe
with uh frank vincent
really yeah oh wow from newark
look that up harry i think he was in a
comedy troupe with frank vincent from
the sopranos i believe
and i know he was a he's in like a boy
band back in the day
so funny he's he's the heartthrob yeah i
know he's like 5-1
there was a great family guy thing with
joe pesci they're like like this is what
a tough guy used to look like
it's also a testament to his acting
because the guy plays in goodfellas was
like 6'5
he was just like this bruiser crazy
psycho guy and then he's
5'3 but they're like he's so good let
him do it he's so scary in it
so scary just nothing to lose i'll kill
anybody
and a [ __ ] hilarious i saw all these
shitty 90s movies too i saw gone fishing
i saw yeah
in a duffel bag jimmy hollywood i just
loved
pesci so i was just like he's great and
everything
yeah he's a legend that scene in casino
with him and
uh de niro in the in the desert going
back and forth is like
legendary they redid it once with a
kermit and or bert and ernie i think
what and it went viral it was pretty
great dude the last scene of casino
might be
one of the most oh with the uh the tidy
whities
that's one of the worst brutal man
that's a that's a memorable violent
scene but
yeah he's still breathing he's still
breathing oh gosh
too much i saw that too young and and
they put that on tv that was on cable
yeah they cut out like they cut out [ __ ]
but they'll let you show a guy like
beating to death in his underwear
i know with a baseball bat then they
just slide him into a hole
in the dirt i remember on goodfellas
instead of [ __ ] you on tv osb
forget you yeah yeah greg johnson you
said that funny bit about uh
in die hard three he has to go to harlem
with the sandwich board that says i hate
n words
and then they change it on cable to i
hate everyone
which is like doesn't doesn't read at
all the same way
like some guy in harlem be like we gotta
beat that guy up
he hates everyone damn yeah die hard
three
man those movies were fun as hell oh
well die hard one was a game changer for
action movies you know because it was
like it was like arnold before that yeah
yeah and it was like fun he was in every
man he wasn't like giant ripped guy he
was like you know
just this new york cop going out to la
they made fun of l.a
there's no snow i i was just so layered
and so much
more fun that this regular guy is like
lost in a skyscraper
and uh then they just redrawn vo johnson
from family matter
so good in that movie i love that guy
dude i loved family matters growing up i
did too
by the way side note reginald johnson
the most type cast man in history
cop on family matters cop and die hard
cop and turtle and hooch
and cop in ghostbusters he's great
though he's great he's great i love him
yeah urkel was like that was such a
perfect show for kids
it was so stupid it was like classic
like this is what you mock now
did i do that like this is the cheesiest
[ __ ] ever i know
i loved everyone on that show i love
daddy i loved all of them yeah we watch
it all and here's the crazy part about
that show
that show is a spin-off of the
elevator operator and perfect strangers
that was the mom
whoa and that's where that show came
from which is like this is what we're
going off of the elevator operator
who had two lines of show on this you
know fish out of water sitcom
[ __ ] from the late 80s and then that
became
family matters which sucked and then
they introduced urkel and then it became
popular
damn and i just went all urkel and then
they were just basically doing the nutty
professor when he became stefan
yeah that's right that's right wow good
point dude perfect strangers i love
i love that [ __ ] i'd watch it with my
dad he's like balky's on get in here you
know
you're missing top-notch comedy gold
here this guy's from uh you know
slovakia or whatever the hell he was
from beverly hills cop
oh man so good i got rules
do we talk about two two guys raised by
tv
i'm like talking about the origins of
family matters
i loved it though man wait did you give
a peeve
do better do better that was yeah that's
[ __ ] good sorry the boost
you got a wreck uh i do it's a weird one
oh good so i got a weird one too so uh
first i got a shout out dana gould who i
love uh he told me to read
the watchmen the graphic novel dude i
never read a graphic novel in my life
that basically you know you know i read
comic books when i was a kid but sure
this is some adult [ __ ] i love it and i
watched the watchmen show on tv and i
couldn't get into it i was the same way
it wasn't for me i didn't love it the
the graphic novel was brilliant dude i
love it
i'm like halfway i finished it i'm like
halfway through on the from the flight
from back from uh seattle but
really you're the nerd guy on the flight
with the graphic novel i was like [ __ ]
it i'll read it
you know it's so good wow now get
clue me in because i i always pushed
back on the graphic novel
well it's it's got so much depth every
character it opens with a murder
and this guy is murdered and and they're
kind of like how was he murdered he's so
big and strong and they kind of don't
know how it happened
and you find kind of figure out who this
guy was and he was part of the superhero
group back in the day
but he was a bad guy he tried to rape
another superhero
he was a bad human being he [ __ ]
kills someone in
a really cold i want to reveal but a
really cold-blooded way and you're like
man this is kind of dark and fascinating
and then
whoa these other superheroes are all
these tortured people
but they're all so three-dimensional
that it feels so real and the problems
are so real it's war
it's uh you know uh drama within this
group of superheroes it's
uh someone's picking them off and some
of them are too smart for their own good
and these characters are so complex
that it just sucks you right in and it's
by alan moore and i think dave
was it gibbons who did it the animation
so alan moore sold it he wanted nothing
to do with the shows he
i think he got a [ __ ] deal from dc and
was like [ __ ] you i want nothing to do
with it
oh it's dc yeah so they i think got the
rights i could be wrong
they got the rights i believe and then
uh it
you know got made into a movie he made a
lot of other stuff he did like v for
vendetta
oh wow he did uh right from hell he's
done a lot of stuff that got adapted but
he wants nothing to do with any of it
yeah because i think
yeah he's he's just like they ruined my
[ __ ] i won't even watch it
interesting and he got a bad deal so he
doesn't want to i don't so i don't know
what the financial situation is but like
this dude's clearly a genius like
clearly yeah
definitely he's got all that in his head
that's amazing so
i was like wow this is pretty damn good
i've never read a graphic novel so dana
was like you gotta check it out you're
not gonna
you think you won't like it you're gonna
love it and you did we worked on a
superhero show idea together and
and he was like just read this it's
great it'll be a good
template for you i'm i love it i'm
always impressed with anyone who gets a
wreck and goes with it most people are
like
yeah i go with his wrecks all the time
because he has great taste
sure chase is so good yeah yeah i know
what you got to trust the guy yeah to go
with the wreck but
wow now because i know friends who who
love it and i always push back on
watching them like
it's got a cape okay oh it's incredible
though really
i mean dude it's it's the the dialogue
is noir esque it's like very it's very
kind of noir
i love it and it's a it's just a book
with a lot of pictures basically
pictures but great lines oh interesting
all right all right
it's it's a lot of dialogue there'll be
pages with no pictures there'll be a few
pages in a row with no pictures
sometimes they'll just be writing
oh okay i didn't know that i thought it
was just all because they're very glossy
and kind of nice
yeah so i always thought it was just
basically a picture book
i i've never i'm new to it so i'm a i'm
a noob in this area
yeah man i i loved it i i'm not done
with it yet but i'm loving it so i uh
i'm gonna stick with it for sure all
right that's a great wreck
i would have never thunk i would have
never thunk either but uh
man it's really i'm trying to be that's
another thing i want to be a little open
here yeah
good good that's good love open no one's
open anymore
i love that everybody's got their niche
they got their we're all so splintered
you know we all have this is the podcast
i like the show i like
it's good to open up not only that but
maybe
like you know if i can't ever sell this
show because i love this show so much
like
i will make it as a graphic novel ah
so you gotta know about them if you're
gonna know it yeah that makes sense
because sometimes it's so hard to make a
show you gotta like
you gotta just own the ip to make the
show right
right there's so much corporate
strangulation with shows now oh yeah
marvel owns every marvel's everything
yeah
yeah they really are they're taking over
and then disney owns marvel
yeah so then disney's taking over like
disney plus apparently is like the most
watched and then netflix really yeah
kids
and then parents just leave it on like
hey you watch this get out of my hair
and disney plus is the simpsons oh yeah
they got the simpsons they got all the
disney and all the marvel so like
they're [ __ ] killing it what's your
rack uh well i got a weird one as well
not as weird as that but um you know
we're on the road a lot i'm always
staring at my phone i'm always on
instagram
trying to find a clip whatever it is
the best follow for me on instagram
is sportscenter i'm not a big
i'm not a huge sports guy i don't really
keep up with it i like mma and some
other stuff but
this is the most uplifting follow
everything is like
doom and gloom or we're in hawaii we're
in tulum
uh we got married we had a kid and
you're like all right all right
this is like guys like trying to lift a
weight and the other guy's behind him or
like basketball [ __ ] where the guy makes
it from the half court all his friends
go
nuts it's always this weird uplifting
kind of
crazy uh you know like
once in a lifetime shot that he made or
a hole in one
or and look i don't care about badminton
or volleyball but the way
you just see the team come together and
they score the winning goal they all hug
and all it's it's a beautiful thing
and it's always obviously if they're
putting it on it's some kind of
spectacular event happen
where like a guy broke a record or
whatever it is but it's
so uplifting and positive huge wreck
i i mean i got more for you if you like
that because i'm all about that dude
yeah
how's the highlights that's a good oh
house of highlights highlights
bleacher reports a good follow one of my
favorites timeless sports
timeline so it's like kind of throwback
stuff i mean i'm sure harry you follow
that right
yeah i like it it's great i mean i love
i sent phil hanley clips all the time
because he loves basketball clips so
i sent him like the best of allen
iverson last night
and i would just wrote like pure heart
and he wrote back like that best way to
describe it like it's a little guy just
hitting step back shots yeah yeah 511
smaller
ap right i mean i i love it man i love
i love the yeah you're talking about the
marine lifting yeah yeah yeah
i loved that moment was his other
marines are cheering him on right he
like deadlifts 6 30 or some [ __ ]
yes yeah and look you could all be like
oh look at these meat heads or whatever
we can do that all day camaraderie man i
was all about it exactly i think it's so
cool and i
i love uh i love great i mean i just
love basketball so i love watching
just amazing passes or shows yeah yeah
and there's comedy too like the shack
stuff where he's talking
to nick jonas like hey nick you know and
all that that that's fun too
shaq's a great follow shaq's great yeah
i love i mean i love
you can't not love shay yeah yeah dad
was a cop
but he and he's got a i think he's got a
badge oh really
i think i got like an honorary badge he
wanted to be a cop how funny would it be
if there was like a drug bust and shaq
just kicks a door in you know
yeah yeah they'd be like damn shaq and
then he would cuff him
he's [ __ ]
there could eventually be a buddy cop
movie with shaq oh yeah no doubt about
it i mean his acting might not be great
he's basically hightower from police
academy i don't know how well
the folks at home know police academy oh
i remember but yeah yeah no it's so it's
just so fun and everything is like
so angry now and complaining that it's
fun to see
just good stuff and that's what's great
it's like that's weird too it's nice
it is it is like hard work yes it is
cool
that's a great way to put it yeah
because it's all like i
you know we don't have enough women on
this show we don't know like all right
everybody's like kind of trying to find
this
way in or complain about that and these
guys like i'll make it work this woman
is a a volleyball star or a weightlifter
whatever it's like
i gotta do the work and win this trophy
or beat my opponent and
and i think it's it's nice to see
and uh yeah great follow it i know
i i know i'm a hack i'm like it's got
eight million views on each no no i
i think sports follows in general yeah
that's a good follow i'm with you
it's a metaphor for life like go for it
try
fail get back up do it again and uh
i think we need some of that now you
know we just blame everybody else all
the time and it's good to see people
just like going for it
yeah i love that stuff man it's
i need that boost me too and we all look
at social media too much so you should
be able to
follow follow accounts that don't drag
you down
yes exactly i mean we're posting jokes
all the time for a reason
yeah yeah here here i'm trying to not be
an account that's like i had a bad
day today and i want you guys to hear
about it i know i know or like here's me
and my boyfriend
on the beach in uh you know virgin
islands and everybody's
you know most people see that and go ah
[ __ ] i'm like cool i've never taken a
vacation
yeah so it that even though that is
positive that bums you out
in a weird way because you compare we
all compare you're missing out right
you're missing out for more
we are missing out because we do so much
stand up like it's funny i you know i
see adrienne i palucci at the uh
gotham line so funny she's one of the
best comics i mean she's if you don't
follow her on everything follow
so many of my favorite jokes she has so
much good news she's maybe my favorite
joke where she goes
you know my boyfriend threatened to kill
himself and i thought great now i can't
kill myself or people are going to think
we were in love
she's incredible every joke you're just
like [ __ ] she's got
such a consistent point of view i love
her yeah and she's a good friend but i i
think uh
not for everybody but she's great but
when she yeah but you know what
good good you know what's for everybody
[ __ ]
you know trash yeah mcdonald's is for
everybody so like check out adrian
killer great writer great take great
angles
but she mentioned to you tonight she was
like oh i just uh mark or whatever
or you know and she goes that guy he
just doesn't stop
oh wow she's like like she said i feel
like he can't stay still
she said i feel like you have the same
problem but she's like but mark might be
worse
well that's where we get along we got
the same goddamn
disease of just like gotta keep going
we're sharks we gotta keep going we're
married to the sea you would say
yes not a bad name for the rye sharks
ooh interesting i do like fat cats i
like fat cat
i like because i like it because it's a
double meaning because fat cat is also
like
successful but it's a funny image effect
yeah and ladies like a fat cat
that's true we get the ladies right and
sharks kind of sounds beachy like with
some kind of
you know florida sharks yeah like some
kind of
red lobster [ __ ] pigeons we're
pigeons
we're not shots speaking of that you got
a bit speaking of
nothing yeah that didn't hit tonight
because i i think it's
in there but it's i see it's divisive so
i did a lot of cop
oh [ __ ] that is uh a room divider
what one hit well i have a whole bit
where i compare cop cops to teachers in
the one line that kind of got it grown
was i say uh
you know uh i say i joke i say
one of the jokes is that being a
teacher's heart but then i say no i'm
kidding i think being a cop is much
harder to being a teacher
uh there's no substitute teachers then
then i kind of pause and i go well white
women
oh no no substitute cops yeah i say well
white women
and that and that kind of gets a laugh
like i see some people like not loving
it tonight
and then i say uh you know that just
feels though it feels like
the setup like that's a funny setup but
there's more
kill in seattle oh but then yeah but now
but then yeah
okay and then i say white women are a
lot like uh
actually a lot like cops because you
know uh they're constantly telling us
how brave they are
i'm scared of them yeah and they're
responsible for the incarceration of a
lot of innocent black men
that's great i mean that feels like a
bit to me killed in seattle tonight it
was
the most stone stone-cold silence i've
ever seen in a fairly packed room and i
was like
well there you go damn and then i had a
lot of cockpits
they probably were a lot of white women
there a lot all right well that's a
factor i think it's funny for white
women too
i think it is too but i did on the early
show gotham all white women killed
oh late show got dead silence you know
why because they were probably those
type of women you hit home maybe yeah
but that's funny i mean
i said it to you i was like what about
karen's and then you were like
go white women is better oh i ran this
by you
yeah oh yeah oh yeah karen is is you
know it's kind of like
i don't like karen is a punchline i
think i don't like it either i don't
like i don't like any word is a punch
line that's not a word that people
it's almost like it's too buzzy it's
buzzy but it's also just like
it's over like i don't want a punchline
that literally
the most funny people i've ever met are
using as a punchline yeah my uncle
was she a karen exactly exactly yeah we
gotta we gotta
go up above that yeah as professional
yeah i know we gotta we gotta
find a different angle yeah more
original angle so yeah
i mean that's great it's something i i
like it but it [ __ ] got
zilch and a lot of white women come out
of these shows
so oh yeah but i still think it's funny
that it should work for them you know
well i think we are getting to a place
where like
white women weren't really a punchline
before and now they are and i think
a lot of them are kind of like sick of
it we have to listen to white men being
trash all [ __ ] day why can't i make a
joke too
i mean prior was doing white men or
trash in 78 so like yeah yeah
get used to it sister this is part of it
but also like i hear so many female
comments being like
white men yeah i'm like cool that's fine
but i should get to do it too
exactly exactly what what what the
hell's this equality talk i've been
hearing
yeah let's uh let's all do it let's
share the wealth
so yeah i think i think that's gold i
think there's a lot there
uh white women are even scarier too
because they don't need guns
cops have guns white women don't have
guns and they still get [ __ ] done
like i'm still scared of you yeah
there's something about like a white
woman will just like
a cop will kill you but a white woman
will like kill you emotionally
yeah they'll like beat you down she'll
kill you over time right
right yeah she'll put a little
antifreeze in your oatmeal
but we've got to watch it you'll never
snap your cop like you'll never be like
are you trying to ruin my life
that's that's hilarious yeah that's so
true
ah yeah you know we've all
been like man these this cop's a dick
but no one's ever like this cop is uh
you know eating away at my soul yeah you
know where
we've all had that girlfriend who's just
you know like no cop has ever gone your
mom's a [ __ ]
i'm like [ __ ] you [ __ ] i introduce you
to my mom you call her a couch
she's a saint
[Laughter]
you're half the one my mom with that but
yeah
anna cops never told me i had a small
dick how about that
melissa you know i'm talking about you
all right
um but yeah and a cop never [ __ ] one of
my friends
all right sorry melissa text me
cops will never cops will plan evidence
but uh a woman will
i maybe they both they both look through
your [ __ ] without a wand oh
that's great is that something great
that's big they're both looking through
your [ __ ]
that looks great what's this [ __ ]
you can't pull a warrant on a girlfriend
though at least a copy like hey you need
a warrant you know girlfriend's like hey
we're dating
you know yeah then maybe there's
something there the warrant
that's big the warrant is bad i got
something to work on what do you got
that's funny uh all right this is a big
bit
and you're not gonna like it so
let's see what happens why would i like
it because it's like
you're like jews are terrible where are
you going well that bit's working
no um it's so against the grain
that maybe it's two against the grain oh
so you feel like you're showing off a
little with it
no not that just like i can't get some
crowds to
get on board sure because it's like so
the wrong way all right all right well
you weren't sure this is dick fuel so i
expect nothing less
this is a gift some guy said it to me so
i said hey i'll wear it
so i got this whole bit about you know
uh you know very left-leaning
progressive all my friends
are like hey these people hate groups
it's so horrible to just hate a group
that you've never met blah blah blah but
then they go [ __ ] rich people
and i'm like well that sounds like
pretty hateful you know they're like
well
you know i hate the one percent and i'm
like so you hate minorities
you know and that hits that's a good
line and there's a there's a lot of
lines in it but i can tell the
overarching theme they're like i don't
know and i'm like
the whole point is like all rich people
are evil all these billionaires are evil
i'm like yeah well some are
and some are nice like that's how people
work you know all cops are bad well some
are bad and then some are great
teachers are heroes so some are heroes
and some [ __ ] they're students
you know like you can't say down with
hate and then hate an entire group
you know and there's because you guys
preach compassion
but you're not compassion about these
people because they're doing better than
you
so uh for some reason you're allowed to
openly hate them
and i have this line that hits about
like some rich guys like yeah my beach
house burned down in malibu and
everybody's like boo [ __ ] who you
know and he's like well my kids were in
there
oh that's good and that kills but it's
still
not completely connecting like some of
the lines are good enough
to to hang in there and and hit but as a
whole overarching theme i can tell
they're not on board
it's hard yeah i think i like it all
right
here's what i i like bits that are kind
of contrarian i don't think yes i don't
think you're saying it
just to poke know i think i think you're
trying to like i'm confused
i think yeah exactly i think i think
it's coming from an honest place
i think because also we're trying to be
rich
so like we're all trying to get to this
thing it's like making fun of that's why
a lot of people i
to me that's why a lot of people i think
don't turn on the rich
like when a lot of people was like you
should be more mad about the wealth and
equality
you could be [ __ ] working you know
you could be like
working the fryer at mcdonald's and be
like i still got a shot
right that's that's what america does
yeah it tells you that you can
make it and you can get rich so i think
that's why a lot of people don't hate
the rich
yes but especially the poor the poor
look up to we're like wow man uh bezos
is awesome
how cool is that and then i know i don't
know if they think he's awesome after
buying that uh half a billion dollar
yacht
yeah that was bad that was kind of bad
that was kind of a [ __ ] move right
there but i think they're like i'd like
to have a yacht i'd like to get some of
that you know what are you doing a half
a billion dollar yacht though it's like
i know it's a little mush and of course
it's a little much yeah yeah that was
the understatement of the century hey
jeff
a little much now uh i think yeah i like
the idea that like
hey you can't hate everybody yeah
it's a classic [ __ ] where it's like [ __ ]
all white men you're like you have a
white
brother yeah you have a white father you
hate him i love him well then why all
white man
exactly it's the same [ __ ] with like
[ __ ] rich people yes do you know any
rich people
i mean they're there are philanthropists
i mean you you could hate
yes even with bill gates you could hate
bill gates he's
raised in i mean the gates foundation
foundations raised the most insane
amount of money i talked about that
for philanthropy i mean so
there's people that are [ __ ] with
their money and there's people that are
i mean
i think that's that's the crux of the
bit you got to bring up
rich people they love i think that you
got to find
something interesting because bill g
i've done
so much research because the bid is so
hard to pull off
yeah bill gates has given back so much
money that he saved six million lives
like he fed these people and whatever
and i'm like that's a reverse holocaust
wow like you'd think you'd stop hating a
guy after he pulled that off because
you've done nothing
and you hate him sure he's rich and
whatever but like
he pulled off a reverse holocaust these
kids are only getting like 10 million
each which sounds like a lot but when
you're worth like
dropping the bucket when you're worth
what he is worth it's kind of a [ __ ] you
yeah yeah exactly so my point is like
look i get it he makes a lot of money he
doesn't need it all
obviously but doesn't mean he's a bad
guy
or a bad woman or whatever it is like
you want to be rich and all my rich
friends hate the super rich and all my
poor friends
look up to them and just because you're
poor that doesn't make your rich friends
hate the rich
yeah they're really rich you know my
millionaire friends hate
billionaires they tweet about like oh
[ __ ] this guy blah blah i'm like
well you're you're also kind of rich
well actually you're are you are rich
not kind of but like just because you're
poor doesn't make you good
you know they're like well bernie madoff
he don't need all the money stole my
whatever i'm like well that
the poor guy stole my wallet it's just
people suck
and people are great like people are
people people suck and some people are
better
at sucking yeah they just figured it out
and you want to figure it out maybe but
i don't know i think there's a lot here
and there's like a deeper
issue but it's just weird why do we hate
why do we hate
the super wealthy because i think cause
they a they're doing better than us
it's a lot of like with jewish shame
like jews were held down
and like you know uh restricted
everywhere and yet they run the
you know they banks real estate media
the weather
it's [ __ ] impressive and i think this
you weren't supposed to know about that
last one
but there's some shame there like [ __ ]
how did they do all that
i thought they were pieces of [ __ ] you
know and now they're killing it and
they're doing better than me
and i thought i was better than them to
[ __ ] them that's what people think
that's what people think there's a it's
a human nature thing there is i think
there's an
element of
this is heavy stuff okay i agree think
there's an element of
arrogance where like and racism
sometimes i mean but like think about
like when sports when people say shut up
and dribble like how
[ __ ] up that is that's [ __ ] up
athletes when you're like
lebron james you don't have to like him
he's entitled to say whatever the [ __ ]
he wants he is a major figure
best basketball player on the planet
exactly and also
he's a pretty successful businessman i
mean aside from being great at this
it's so weird when people say you know
shut up and dribble is crazy
like you can't have a point or a thought
or an opinion
there is something about that's
interesting shut up and dribble once you
get
once you get really rich
no it's like you're doing this cerebral
bit and then you're like
oh hold on sorry let me it's a thinker
i'm aware
and i know there's a lot here and a lot
to unpack and all that but like
i just don't understand the down with
hate
but [ __ ] these people because they're
doing better than me they're doing well
so we're allowed to hate is it about how
you were born maybe if it was if you
were born really rich
then you can hate them because that's
like but then if they if you became rich
but i think it's either way they hate
you it's either they hate either way and
being born rich is not that baby's fault
you know like and it doesn't mean
they're evil they're just rich
they just have a lot of money doesn't
make them bad people there's also
poor people is it the rich people hate
or is it the old is it bill
is it millionaires or is it billionaires
do you think it's both i think it's a
little of both like elon musk
obviously is a gigantically wealthy guy
enormously wealthy but
he hosts snl and like the go-to thought
is like ah [ __ ] that guy
like he could be a sweet guy and he
could be nicer than you
yeah you know but you just see him as
this
it's like i'm not saying it's like
judging somebody by the color their skin
but you're judging somebody by what they
have or what they've done
it is technically the opposite of
slavery they're the people that had
slaves
yeah yeah i guess but it's like
i don't know it just feels like for
someone saying down with hate it feels
weirdly unnecessarily hateful
yeah it's it's it's interesting yeah
they're they're i'm throwing a big one
at you here i know i know
it sounds like crack right now it's like
you're angry at them for having more
than you that's the
i think that's the bottom line i think
that's no pun intended but i think
that's the underlying
um issue there you're mad that they have
more i mean i think it comes down to
that and it's like
[ __ ] them well how about but then it's
like
then there's people that have less than
you and they look at you like [ __ ] you
and you're like well that we're always
gonna be that's interesting we're always
going to be
in that place yeah yeah but that's not a
good place to be just worry about your
[ __ ]
get your [ __ ] together and do what you
like to do and be with the people you
like to be with i
just it shouldn't be [ __ ] the riches
should be [ __ ] the rich if they made
their money in a [ __ ] up way
there you go that's completely insane
and completely fair
but like the the mustang is so weird
he's like this incredibly
environmentally
sound guy who's trying to help the
environment we got tesla and all that so
it's like we hate this guy he's
i thought it was thought we were trying
to help i think people just hate anyone
who
who made it like a bandit during the
pandemic and he's one of them ah
is that what it is yeah i mean he was
already rich but i think now he's
the richest right and yeah you've got
is it because you didn't get married yet
that's how you hold on to the [ __ ]
under the title yeah i guess so
bezos and gates maybe bill gates just
needed to go through i i
i'm gonna [ __ ] everything phase maybe
that's what he was doing yeah
i i think you got something with the uh
the poor people
maybe look at millionaires like [ __ ] you
and you're like well what did i do well
that's how they feel the billionaires
feel about you
that's interesting i think that's
something when you put yourself in those
shoes
yeah why are they mad are they mad
because i think you know you could go
deeper like oh it's because
do they have tax breaks over you or is
it really just because they have more i
think that's really it that i
think that's really it if we're really
getting down their life
is easier that's that's what that's what
they're mad about
your apartment's bigger your life is
easier you have
you just have an easier go i think
that's what the anger is but if they
earned it
i don't know i think it's okay it's like
when the hot girl walks into the party
and your girlfriend's like i don't like
her
like oh you don't like her but she she
might be a great person does it come
down to
how they earned it because look there's
comics that are way more successful than
us and we look at their acts and we're
like
ugh that's true so
do we have to respect them for earning
it no but
they just got opportunities and
look it's annoying i get it i'm human i
get jealous or whatever but
they're not going to turn it down so i
can't blame them i blame the dumb
industry
blame the when an nba player gets
i remember alan houston for the knicks
got like an insane contract and he was
injured the whole contract everyone was
like why'd they pay this guy
it's not his fault they hated him but
it's like not his fault not his fault
team paid
exactly and he didn't ask to get injured
it was an accident or whatever
yeah so it happens so yeah it's an
interesting it's a thinker it's a it's a
brain twister but
i think that's kind of fun now we've
been doing comedy long enough let's
let's take a big scoop out of the the
pot and see if we can [ __ ] with it
yeah that's a horrible analogy but you
know what i mean let's uh let's
try to it's like chopped all right give
me this this this weird give me the the
shrimp
give me the the parsley and the the
grape jelly and let's see if we can make
something with it
parsley grape jelly what was the other
one shrimp
it's gonna be a weird one oh yeah it's
gonna be like a sweet shrimp i'm gonna
have to throw some hot sauce in there
make it like sweet and spicy
there you go there we go do you think
you'd be good on shaft
maybe are you a good cook no i'm
horrible i'm horrible i was
you made chili and i almost blew you oh
i remember that yeah
come on i was blown away by the chili
but i think i'd be decent on chopped if
uh
if i could get the host high that might
not ron funch's show oh
is it i think that i think that's ron's
show i think you get he gets high and
eats it
oh that's funny it's pretty good i've
been seeing it yeah i i
watch it i like those shows yeah i do
too i do too i watch job for hours and
pawn stars
i like i like it's funny how angry we
were in reality tv started now i'm just
like too tired to care
i know i will sit there and wait till
they do the uh the storage
thing i'm like all right you got me
we're two minutes in but i want to know
what's in that goddamn unit
there was nothing in there but garbage
bags and uh like an old mattress i'm
like god i wasted
20 minutes of my life on this [ __ ]
and that's most of america watching this
we should wrap this up right yeah jesus
christ where are you going to be coming
up
oh man i'm all over the road this comes
out in what three months
i will be in uh hartford funny bone
spokane following in your footsteps
virginia beach funny bone
uh orlando florida improv san antonio
helium portland uh syracuse toledo
houston philly buffalo
dayton uh appleton arlington texas
brea in california can't wait for that
funny bone albany
and uh west palm beach i got arlington
we're going to add a wednesday for that
so yeah
see you there uh wednesday through
saturday uh we got
uh albany funny bone fourth and fifth
or yeah we got uh atlantic city the 11th
and 12th
uh tampa side splitters the 17th through
the
uh 19th of june we got raleigh the 25th
through the 27th
and uh we gonna keep on rocking man we
got madison comedy on state coming up we
got okc
hell yeah we got all kinds of fun gigs
coming up i can't wait uh
governor's in levittown and make sure
you uh
make sure you hit up our patreon
patreon.com
we might be drunk pod also email us
at uh we might be drunk pod at gmail.com
with your jokes your peeves your wrecks
your drinks
this is this went down easy oh my god i
wanted three more bottles this is so
good
well done sir i get why this guy was a
legend so good
very good yeah send us a patreon tell a
friend about the pod get a drink
watch it with your pals it's on youtube
it's on spotify it's on itunes
all the good stuff shout out to gotham
studios for having us we love
uh doing the show here they're doing
such a great job matt
appreciate you harry producing this
bad boy here too we love it uh you know
we appreciate you guys and uh
keep listening tell your friends if
you're liking it yeah come see us live
watch our specials we got
tons of content out there and uh yeah
praise all
uh we'll see you in hell
good afternoon oh my god i know i stayed
up but that was one of my faves that
felt like uh
it felt like the most natural
conversation we've ever had patreon do
we do a quick one now or do we do
i think we do it now just to get it
going